there's been a real desire to bring new
technology into the surgical suite or
providing better visualization or giving
them better information we're doing a
more automated way much better for the
patient better for the surgeon better
for the healthcare system as well
neurosurgeons across North America now
have the power to see inside their
patients like never before and save more
lives time and thousands of dollars
because of it that's thanks to synaptic
medical a maker of computerized
equipment that help surgeons plan
practice and execute minimally invasive
micro surgeries with an unprecedented
level of clarity I think for a long time
people have kind of thought there's a
blank cheque for healthcare the blank
cheque is is over
and people are realizing there's limited
resources if you look at our system the
payback period at a fairly busy Hospital
can be as short as six months so typical
investment in technology they look for a
payback period of five years so that
kind of tells you how much we're bending
the cost curve for these hospitals the
product lineup is called broad matter
and it starts with a software that uses
a type of MRI to build detailed 3d
images of a patient's brain all the
different colors represent the different
directions of tracks in the brain the
surgeon can plan a round of these tracks
so that it is basically going to the
safest way possible as the procedure
unfolds a robotic arm outfitted with a
special camera tracks the movement of
the surgeons tools and broadcast the
feet onto monitors in front of them you
can see an orange that is my target that
I'm trying to hit and now if I want to
use our robotic arm I can align directly
down this trajectory of my pointer tool
synaptic uses feedback from surgeons to
help it fine-tune its products doctor
Sunita - at Saint Michael's Hospital in
Toronto is one of the physicians who has
offered his input
took care of a young gentleman found to
have a what looked like a low-grade
brain tumor the approach surgically that
I would typically take would go through
an area of the brain that contains some
of the fiber tracts that are responsible
for vision though what the synaptic
software was able to do was actually
reconstruct those fibers and it let me
perform a surgery for this young man and
I was able to do it without injuring its
visual function some medical
institutions are hesitant to by robotic
surgical tools for two reasons one there
isn't much data around their
cost-effectiveness and two they carry
hefty price tags but synaptic medical
believes early studies offer a
compelling sales pitch for example
researchers at Toronto Western Hospital
found that minimally invasive micro
surgeries like the ones bright matter
are used in typically take less time
than traditional surgeries patients also
tend to stay in the hospital for fewer
recovery days bright matter is already
being used in several American
institutions including the Grady Health
System in Atlanta one of the busiest
trauma centers in the southeastern
region the products also received
regulatory clearance in Canada this
summer
synaptic hopes some positive reviews for
bright mato will help bring more
hospitals on board this is a emerging
trend I think across the world is the
focus on return on investment for
technology they purchase which is
challenging the very exciting